-♪ Will U B My BFF ♪
♪ Will U B My BFF ♪
-It's time for your favorite
game show, "Will U B My BFF?"
And here's your host,
Flip Jansen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Aha-ha!
Well, welcome to
"Will U B My New BFF?",
the only game show
where we help someone
find a new best friend forever.
And let's meet the lucky person
who's about to have
a new bestie.
Her name is Gigi.
She is a supermodel
who calls New York City
her home.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh.
Hi, Gigi.
You ready to meet
your new best friend?
-What's up?
I am so ready.
-Now, what do you look for
in a new best friend?
-Loyalty.
-Mm-hmm.
-Funny.
-Sure.
-And chill.
-Chill. I like that.
And now it's time to meet
the three contestants.
They're DTF -- down to friend.
[ Laughter ]
Let's meet them.
Contestant number one
has a personal vendetta
against broccoli rabe.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Contestant two number's
favorite candy
is Sour Patch Kids,
and he loves the movie "Ghost."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And contestant number three
won't ever forget your birthday
and will gladly give you
the login
to all of his
streaming services.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, that's nice.
-That's expensive now.
-It is expensive.
We've met our three contestants.
Now for our first round
of questions.
And one more thing.
Our contestants will be speaking
in a chipmunk voice,
so you won't be able to tell
who they are.
All right, Gigi,
it's time to meet your 'munks.
Go ahead
and ask your first question.
-Contestant number two,
we're throwing a dinner party
for all our friends.
What theme would you pick
to make sure
it was the best
dinner party ever?
-[ High-pitched voice ] Ooh.
-Ooh.
-I think I would like to go
with a murder mystery.
-Ooh.
-You know, maybe emphasis
on the murder.
[ Laughter ]
Actually, no,
I'm gonna take that back.
Let's do, like,
a nativity scene.
-No, wait --
[ Laughter ]
-Now pick your poison.
-I liked murder mystery.
-Oh.
-That was good.
-There you go.
Time for your next question
for contestant number three.
-Contestant number three,
we're splitting nachos
at our favorite restaurant,
and we're down to the last one.
What do you do?
-[ High-pitched voice ]
Have you ever
"Lady and the Tramped" a nacho?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh!
Hey-oh!
All right, thank you,
contestant number three.
Gigi, what you got for them?
-Contestant number one,
I'm a huge animal lover.
What is your favorite animal,
and can I hear an impression,
please?
-[ High-pitched voice ]
Uh, maybe I'm gonna have to go
with something French
like, uh, the "lee-on."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, uh...
-Gosh!
-...the "lee-on" says...
- let's hear the impression.
-...roar!
-Ooh!
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Okay, contestant number three,
what's your favorite animal?
Give us an impression.
-Hi.
That's the impression,
because I'm the animal.
I'm a party animal.
-Oh! Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nice.
-Hi.
-Well, we're down
to our final round.
Gigi,
what's your first question?
-Contestant number two,
it's 8:00 p.m.
I text you that everyone's
forgotten my birthday.
What do you do
to help salvage the day?
-And I'm gonna say,
"Happy birthday.
It's your birthday?
I probably forgot your birthday,
too.
Sorry."
[ Laughter ]
I'm the friend
who's gonna be honest.
-There you go.
Nicely done. Nicely done.
All right, Gigi,
this is the last question.
-What song would you sing
at karaoke with me,
and can you sing some of it
right now?
-♪ And I-I-I-I-I-I ♪
♪ Will always love y-o-o-ou ♪
♪ I will always love y-o-o-ou ♪
-Beautiful voice.
That's heartbreaking, isn't it?
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right.
You've heard
from all the contestants.
Now it's time to see
who your best friend is.
Will it be
contestant number one?
Contestant number two?
[ Cheers ]
Or contestant number three?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Likes nachos...
I think I'm going with
contestant number three.
-Whoa!
Number three, you're the winner!
Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Normal voice ] We nailed it!
-There you have it,
ladies and gentlemen!
Number three
is your new best friend.
-Congratulations to my
new best friend, Gigi Hadid!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're talking to Gigi
after the break.
Stick around, everybody!
Come on back.